um well i just want to bring you some
breaking news uh bakayo saka the 19 year
old
england player who was one of the
players to miss uh
that spot kick in the final against
italy and was subjected to some vile
racist abuse online has made his first
social media post
uh since that final on the sunday a
really powerful statement i'm gonna
bring you some of it now
he's taken aim at social media companies
he has this
to say to the social media platforms
instagram
twitter and facebook i don't want any
child or adult to have to receive the
hateful and hurtful messages that me
marcus and jaden have received this week
i knew instantly the kind of hate that i
was about to receive and that is a sad
reality that
your powerful platforms are not doing
enough to stop
these messages there is no place for
racism or hate of any kind in football
or in any area of society and to the
majority of people coming together to
call out the people sending these
messages
by taking action and reporting these
comments to the police
and by driving out the hate by being
kind to one another
we will win love always wins
bakayo an incredibly
moving and powerful statement from the
19 year old england player bakayoteka
after being subjected to vile racism
online on platforms
that he is directly talking to their
instagram
facebook and twitter